goosebumps every time I need that what
is up guys in today's video I'm be
showing you a super easy way to make
money overnight every single night it is
super easy all you have to do is buy
items that are highly traded and then
buy them for a seriously low price maybe
10 GP than they normally sell for maybe
even less so the way that I figured this
out I went on GE tracker a sponsor of
mine the link is in the description if
you want to sign up I went to the high
volume items and I searched through all
of these basically any of these items
will work if you buy them overnight I
did a bunch of them I'll show you them
in a second but all these items will
work really well now I will show you the
items that I used so these are the
prices and the items that I used I used
to see cannonball the gold amulet you
grapes Snape grass mithril bolts bow
strings coal and then I also bought
wizard boots because the profits are
normally pretty good over night now I
will go ahead and get off and I will
pick in the morning all right it is now
the morning okay it looks like a lot of
items sold just let me put in my pin
real quick okay so most of the items
sold I'll go ahead and collect them all
so the gold amulet use did not all sell
the bowstring sit on i'll sell and thus
named Crescent on I'll sell I put in an
offer over the buy limit overnight for
cannonballs so that's why I couldn't buy
them all but now I will go ahead and
check the prices of all these so what
I'm doing I'm just buying the max price
so that I can see how much I can sell
them for and see if I am making a profit
so 252 I bought them for 235 while
that's a huge margin so I'll put them in
for 252 that's really like 200k right
there yep 235
2:52 okay so now we'll check the price
on the cannonballs
189 let's see how much I bought them for
so about them for 180 okay so that's 9gp
that's a great margin to 189 let's go
ahead and move it up actually we'll do
190 okay so that's a good margin
let's check the mithril bolts okay max
price Oh 106 wow that's very high let's
see what a bottom for a bottom for 89
okay so that's like an 11 GP or
something
106 105 we'll move it down
animals already sold see that's the
thing I love about the cannibals they
sell so quickly and so easily
alright the coal is sold I'll just sell
back because I don't want that extra one
158 and I bought them for 147 so another
11 GP margin and some of the methyl
bolts have already sold so that's good
sign now check what we sold the wizard
boots for 450 1k okay it says they're
selling for 478 K so I'll go ahead and
put them in for that and I'll just let
these items sit and I'll come back okay
they finally all sold it took about 15
minutes but it's not a big deal because
I just wanted to flip them overnight and
then sell them in the morning
so everything sold for the place that I
wanted so that's perfect I'll go ahead
and collect it all and then I'm gonna go
back through this and do some math so I
can see how much money I made okay now
it's time to see how much money I made
so what I did I added up all the prices
of the items that I sold and then I -
the price of all the items that I bought
and I made sure to mine as a extra one
item from each of these and I actually
found out the amount of money I made
it's actually insane I made in the exact
number which I'm very surprised
so total of what I sold them for seven
million in sixteen thousand - what I
bought them for six million five hundred
sixteen thousand equals an exact 500k
that is insane I did not realize it was
gonna be one I didn't realize it'd be
that much money I made overnight that
easily and - I didn't realize it would
be 500k like what are the odds of it
landing exactly on 500k I feel like
that's very slim and very insane but
anyways guys it's a super easy way to
make money just make sure you look at
the high volume items that are traded
you can use g tracker to do that link is
in my description but if you sell these
items overnight or if you rather you buy
these items overnight it's super easy to
sell them in the morning so go ahead and
do that I hope you guys like this video
thanks for all the love and getting a
lot of comments and a lot of people
messing game so that's been awesome so
keep doing that if you want if you like
this video go ahead and give it a thumbs
up so I know you like these kind of
videos and if you want to leave a
comment go ahead and leave it I'll read
it and try to reply to you guys as soon
as I can but if you're new to the
channel go ahead and subscribe but
thanks guys for watching stay tuned for
my next video